this is a production of cornell
university
uh it's so great to see people's faces
or at least the top half of people's
faces um great to be back in person um
so i'm going to be talking about cider
apples in america starting from
plymouth all the way through the end of
national prohibition
so i'm just going to give a brief
overview of this talk i'm going to be
talking about the history of hard cider
and apple culture in america
and so
starting in the colonial period going
through early republic throughout the
19th century and getting into the early
20th century
and i'm going to be telling this history
through american cider apples so these
are named cultivars that originate in
england and america and they're also a
lot of unnamed cider apples these are
anonymous seedlings species hybrids
and then i'm going to be tying in some
data that we've been collecting in the
pec lab over the last five or so years
mainly juice quality data and some other
phenotypic data about a bunch of these
apples
so i want to start with a quote from
james fitz of virginia who in 1872 wrote
good cider is the wine of america now
this is not a shot across the bow at any
of our viticulture and enology friends
so you know peace i come in peace um
but uh
this quote really struck me so this
seems totally foreign to us in the 21st
century america like how can cider be
the wine of america it's like this niche
product it's barely one percent of the
total alcohol that we consume and buy in
this country
but from the colonial period up to like
the mid-19th century
america's
favorite beverage really was hard cider
it was the most economically important
beverage it was the most widespread
beverage it was grown and made on most
farms in america
beer was sort of this thing it was
produced in cities
and a minority of americans lived at
cities up until fairly recently
historically speaking
and most homestead orchards were from
making cider rather than for having
fresh eating apples or making pie or jam
or whatever
and when i'm talking about cider we
think of just hard cider as you know
that stuff in a can or bottle it's
fermented apple juice but historically
speaking it was a much wider pleiades a
constellation of different apple drinks
so there was cider which i think most of
us have probably tasted and then there
was pomona wine and the sort of lower
rent version of this was called boiled
cider
and so it was cider that was evapo
concentrated and then fermented so it
was stronger because it was more
concentrated sugar and this is similar
to what they call fire cider in quebec
but this tradition actually predates the
quebec tradition by like 200 years or so
um and then this was sometimes also made
by cryo concentrating instead of heat
concentrating so it's sort of like ice
cider then cider royal which is similar
to what people call pomo nowadays
and cider royal was like one part apple
spirit to three or four parts cider
and then apple brandy or cider brandy
which piece of people also called
applejack or
apple whiskey or jersey lightning
and it's called jersey lightning because
one sip of it will strike you like a
lightning bolt it's really strong stuff
so what is a cider apple
so there's this quote and i've sort of
heard people say this and i can't really
remember who i heard say this first so i
can't attribute it to anyone but there's
this idea any apple that's used in cider
is a cider apple and that's very nice
and inclusive and opening you know it's
open and there's no gatekeeping involved
in it but
for the purposes of this and especially
to be historically accurate i'm going to
use a narrower definition of what is a
cider apple
so this comes from charles downing in
1872 he wrote cider apples are varieties
frequently useless for any other purpose
the best for this purpose are rather
tough piquant and astringent their juice
has a high specific quality or specific
gravity so these are very sugar rich
they're astringent
they're spicy they're tart
and they're often not used for anything
else
so we measure the quality of a cider
apple um in its tannin content it's
acidity content it's sugar content and
then finally aroma so um tannin we
measure in the pec lab using the full
and show call 2 method and there are
other methods that people use
but this is the one that we favor
acidities
measured as titratable acidity reported
malic acid equivalents malic acid is the
primary
biological organic acid in apples
sugar is reported as degrees brix
soluble solid concentration and aroma is
a little harder to quantify but it can
sort of be quantified through volatile
analysis
and brittany's doing some stuff on that
with nitrogen and volatile formation in
the fermentation
process uh and then how do we classify
apples once we have all this data so
this is a bit of an anachronism because
this schema was put forth in 1903 in
england and that's like three centuries
after the history of cider began in
america
but it's a useful classification system
this is btp barker of the national cider
institute he and mr edel
came up with this long ashton system
from long ashton england where the
national cider institute was
and so they classified apples on two
axes on their tanning content and their
acid content and some of you might have
heard this before in previous peck lab
talks but a quick refresher for those uh
who haven't um
anything with one point less than 1.2
grams per liter of tannin would be
considered sweet or sharp
and anything above that would be
bittersweet or bitter sharp and then for
acidity it's 4.5 grams per liter or like
0.45
and so generally speaking when i'm
talking about american cider apples most
of them fall into the bitter sharp but
there are certainly cider apples that
fall into all four of these categories
particularly in england and france
so um here in the peck lab
one of the studies we've been doing over
the last five years is a study of the
usda malice collection malice is the
genus that apples fall under and crab
apples
and up in geneva at mccarthy farm
[Music]
there's a massive living collection of
malice
domestica and other
species and hybrids
and we've been analyzing the juice
chemistry of accessions in this
collection that are of interest for hard
cider and this is included as i've found
some historic american cider apples
so now let's get into the history
so before um you know pre-columbian
times there were uh malice species which
we would call crab apples that are
indigenous to this continent
and giacomo de verazano an italian
explorer was sailing up the east coast
in 1523 and he observed that there were
apples many other fruits but they were
all of a different kind from ours and by
ours he means europeans
and these are
malice species
for those native to the east coast their
malice coronaria malus flora bunda which
is more sort of southern southeastern
and mala sciences is like sort of
midwestern but its range also extends as
far east and they're typically quite
small very hard
they're greenish to yellow so they don't
really look like what we think of as an
apple
um
and their skin is very highly aromatic
it's very perfumed it's also very greasy
oily
and from what i've read again i'm not a
member of the hudan nashani confederacy
but from what i've read
in traditional food ways malice
coronaria was sliced and dried or it was
ground up almost as a flower rather than
as we would you know think of an apple
being used
um and i've also read that it was part
of the haranashani creation story so
here is uh an example of malelus
coronaria from the usda collection so as
you can see it's quite small 37-47
millimeters in diameter it's just 25
grams it's really quite tiny
it's very hard in fact our penetrometer
couldn't read the flesh firmness because
it's so stinking hard
very high acid so just as a reminder 4.5
is the minimum to be considered sharp
this is way up at 26. it's also quite
bitter and astringent uh well above 1.2
um
and so this was one of those um native
species that were used in um in
indigenous food ways but uh it was
gradually adopted by
the colonists and later american
settlers and henry david terreaux and
several other people report that it was
used in making hard cider
so then along comes malice domestica
which was brought by european settlers
uh and the exact date is kind of
uncertain we don't know exactly when to
speak well it's really a hybrid of three
species that's why we call it mal's
ex-domestica but um we don't know maybe
it was 1620 in massachusetts maybe it
was earlier with the founding of
virginia
but in
2016-28
the people of massachusetts ordered some
apple seeds from england
john winthrop in 1634 uh ordered grafted
apple trees from england and that same
year lord baltimore who was founding
maryland
primarily for persecuted catholics uh
told his the settlers coming to maryland
bring some apples and pear seeds uh for
making thereafter of cider and perry so
i think this is probably the earliest
mention of people growing these fruit
from making cider in america
and then in sometime around 1639 roxbury
russet the first named domestica
apple uh originated in this continent
so um here's roxbury russet
they think it originated in rockstar
massachusetts
uh it was so beloved that people
actually took it and grafted it in
connecticut and it was
propagated that way
throughout the northeast
um
from what i've read it's not really
often described as being a good cider
apple but people would use basically any
excess apples they had in hard cider so
this was probably part of the
the cider ways i don't know food waste
but the cider ways of the early colonial
period
um and so it's got sort of mild acidity
not much tannin because it's more of a
culinary fresh market apple so we call
it like a mild shark
then along comes hughes virginia crabs
so this the darker cider that is on
everyone's left i believe is a single
variety uh hughes virginia crab and if
you would like please partake of that i
myself will imbibe a little bit
so
this crab apple
originated around 1717 in virginia
wildly popular historically
uh quite beloved for making cider and
there are accounts and newspaper
articles and nurseries and
property records of entire orchards just
planted with hughes virginia crab
and uh there were single variety ciders
similar to the one that we're drinking
right now that were sold throughout the
19th century and they were sold by name
this is
hughes virginia crab cider
and so it's pretty high in sugar
moderate acid and fairly smooth tannins
once it's really ripe and mellow
and we'd call this like an aromatic
bitter sharp
now i would be remiss if i didn't take a
moment to talk about the connection of
hughes in particular but cider making in
general with slavery in america um
so at monticello jefferson's monticello
the north orchard was planted
in part with hughes virginia crab and
darlene hayes just this past year did
some really wonderful research on um
enslaved couple george and ursula
granger who were the
cider maker and cider bottler at
monticello for mr jefferson
uh and so you know the cider industry
and the cider scene you know we have to
acknowledge the contributions of people
who
you know didn't choose to make the
contributions to cider in america and i
found uh records of it growing as far
south as georgia and it's being sold in
nurseries as far as as texas
and here is a lovely illustration of it
by um elizabeth cox mcmurtry who is the
daughter of william cox
and her illustrations have been really
invaluable to homologists as we're
tracking down historic cider apples
and so william cox
a great polymath i believe member of
congress from pennsylvania
wrote a description of how people make
cider out of these apples it's very
labor-intensive to pick them because
they're not very big you can see a
handful of them at the back of the room
after this is done
um and so he describes how people would
mound and sweat in other words let them
sort of ripen and
concentrate a little bit
uh and they would lay them out on the
floor of the cider house and make sure
there was good air flow over them so
people really took care with this apple
to make the best possible cider out of
it as
possible um
and so as i mentioned there were a lot
of single variety ciders sold throughout
america and this wasn't just like a
thing that you'd find in a handful of
areas in virginia this was sold in new
york in new orleans in philadelphia
in lancaster pa norfolk virginia
kansas nebraska missouri this was really
a very um cosmopolitan drink and this
apple in particular was really well
renowned throughout the country as a
cider apple
so um poor one
figuratively not literally poor went out
for some of our likely extinct cider
apples
such as roane's white crab
this was thought to be a seedling of
hues which we just tasted um
it's likely extinct this is the only
illustration of it that survives and
then toliver which was highly esteemed
by jefferson it was the other variety
that he had planted in his north orchard
and there were some others um wildscrab
carolinacrab columbia crab
and now we come to harrison so on your
right is the other cider made from
harrison
this is a famous new jersey cider apple
from newark
and was said to originate in the orchard
of mr samuel harrison in essex county
new jersey it was first described by mr
cox in 1817
and this is another one where people
would advertise their single variety
this is harrison cider i've got harrison
cited for sale
and it was thought to be lost until it
was rediscovered in the 70s at a cider
mill in essex county new jersey
it's fairly high in sugar it's kind of
moderately acidic it's just sort of at
the threshold of being sharp and it's
fairly low in tannins that the phenolics
are probably more sort of spicy or
aromatic than bitter or astringent
and i'm going to taste the harrison now
so definitely less chewy
less tannic but also quite nice
and so here some advertisements that i
found in old newspaper searches on
harris insider so again you know this is
sold in georgia
baltimore
north carolina charleston south carolina
again very cosmopolitan drink
and here is some harrison that we
photographed in the peck lab from the
usda last year
and here's a watercolor from the usda
watercolor collection from 1899 i think
that's a pretty good match
and we've got some harrisons at the back
of the room too if you want to check
them out
and so so far i've been talking about
american
varieties ones that germinated and
originated here but there were also a
lot of english apples uh cider apples
that were brought over from england as
grafted trees uh in early america
um so i found some in a letter from
abraham crocker who's a pomologist from
somerset england
and he was recommending to the american
academy of arts and sciences here are
some great english apples that you
americans in your newfangled country
might enjoy
um william prince senior the prince
family had a very important nursery in
queens long island
um in the late 1700s early 1800s
and then just by chance i found an
advertisement of an orchard for sale in
frog's neck which is now i believe the
bronx
and this person actually took the time
to write out which varieties of cider
apples they had in their orchard which
is just like
i totally nerded that when i found this
it was really
it's really an invaluable historical
research this is one of the only
mentions
of what apple's people were growing at
the time so um the english hey glee crab
white style talk more about um
all these in the next slide so hey glee
crab this has been important to the s
the u.s it actually survives um and it's
coming soon
um cockagey it's just such a strange
name um it's likely extinct and it was
described in the 1850s as perhaps the
most harsh and austere apple known
so maybe that's why it went extinct i
don't know um
and then steyer so there's forest styre
white styre dean styre it's sort of this
catch-all for i believe malice
silvestris which is the west european
crab apple um and it was often found in
gloucestershire in the forest of dean
and people would just take a cutting or
a seedling and
transplant it into their orchards
and then foxwell which uh was a very
highly valued cider apple and into the
20th century people would still pay top
dollar for the juice of this variety
there are a bunch of fox swells floating
around the one in the usda greg has
coined the term foe well because it's
actually
not any of the fox whelps we don't know
what it is
but the true one has been imported by
john bonker in maine that's exciting
and then there was some plant breeding
going on even in the 1700s
thomas andrew knight an english
pomologist made this cross siberian
bittersweet there were others red street
bittersweet white tower etc
so here are some beautiful engravings
from pomona's which are these
illustrated books of apples
and these were digitized thanks to the
fine folks at our very own mann library
and these are again a really really
essential very helpful resource to
people who are trying to track down
these historic apple varieties
uh so so far i've been talking about
named apples
um but there was this
vast uh food system of growing unnamed
sibling apples throughout america
um and so i'm gonna do a brief
digression on unnamed apples
so
these were planted all over the
continent it was way easier to carry a
bag of apple seeds than to carry a bag
of apple trees on your shoulders when
you were moving out west
and so often these trees they'd be
planted
and uh they'd be intended as a root
stock or a stem builder so the tree
would get so big and then once it was
established you'd graft something else
on top of it a named variety that you
liked but just as often people would
sort of say that's good enough and
they'd leave it to stand and they'd use
a lot of the food for hard cider because
it might not have been particularly good
it might not be particularly bad
and uh henry david thoreau in the 1860s
was already looking back sort of
wistfully kind of nostalgically at this
earlier time he was saying it would be a
pleasant past time to find suitable
names for the hundred varieties which go
to a single heap of the cider mill
and
in the early
constitution period right after the
ratification of the constitution there
was this battle i don't know if you
remember american history class between
the federalists and the anti-federalists
and so
similar to today identity politics and
tribalism were very rampant in early
america and people tried and i don't
think they were all that successful but
they tried to co-opt the way people grew
apples and what they used their apples
for as some sort of tribal signifier of
like whether you were a good federalist
or a democrat and back then democrat
meant like populist or like mob rule now
we think of democracy as like democracy
you know um
so uh
according to this schema
um you know federalists believed in
agricultural improvement and grafting
the most tried-and-true varieties and
having well-maintained orchards and they
supported you know a strong congress and
a strong federal government and then
these you know rabbled of democrats they
believed in agricultural subsistence
they just grew their apples for cider or
for applejack and they had these sort of
badly maintained you know
crappy looking trees with
water sprouts and suckers sticking out
of them
and this and again like this is so
similar to our politics today
um people actually tried to turn what
things you drank into some sort of
signifier of what your politics were
it's just so ridiculous um so cider and
beer and porter it's like a low alcohol
ale and pomona wine these were like good
federal drinks for you know uh
better behaved people and then these
rabble were drinking their their
democratic drinks whiskey and rum
and so this um federalist newspaper
tried to actually like tell people um
learn to prize those invaluable federal
liquors beer insider and learn likewise
to despise spiritus liquors as
anti-federal
and this of course
is complete nonsense in case you hadn't
guessed from my tone of voice
um and so just take a look at washington
and jefferson so washington was our
first president under the federal
constitution he was pro-constitution his
pro-federalism and yet he was a
distiller of brandy and whiskey
uh and and spoke quite highly of these
spiritus liquors and jefferson who was
quite skeptical of the constitution and
uh i believe wasn't even present at the
convention uh if i remember correctly he
was very anti-federal certainly he was
the first anti-federalist president
essentially
he was an avid maker and drinker of
cider and promoted cider as like a good
alternative to spiritus liquors
and both of these men were avid
practitioners of grafting and
horticultural science so you know anyone
who tries to say that you know someone
who doesn't agree with my politics
doesn't believe in science that's bogus
it was bogus then it's bogus now
anyway just wanted to make that point
um
so then
the war is over
uh the constitution has been ratified by
the states and westward expansion has
resumed
so dr benjamin rush of philadelphia was
talking about how there was all this
excess population in the cities and
towns in the east coast
and he said that excess population were
like suckers on the tree of eastern
pennsylvania and for the health of the
tree the suckers needed to be removed
but instead of killing them they needed
to be transplanted west so that they
could grow and they could um thrive in
their own soil and so illinois briefly
had the nickname of the sucker steak and
sucker state and one uh
illinoisian said may this sucker air
long become a lofty and magnificent tree
and then most of you have probably heard
of johnny appleseed he was a real person
named john chapman who was planting
seedling nurseries in the ohio river
valley
um and so he was all part of this this
food system of planting seedling apples
and then as people were moving into the
upper midwest they needed more cold
hardy apples to survive the winters in
minnesota and michigan and
illinois and wisconsin and so people
became very interested in the siberian
crab alice bakata and people started
breeding apples using more cold hardy
crab apples
and so that brings us back to more name
cider cultivars what am i doing on time
uh so here's transcendent crab
it's an american seedling of the
siberian crab and it was commended for
crab apple wine by a lot of homologists
and nursery men
uh it's sort of a bitter sharp
here's his slip crab
very similar commended for crab apple
wine kind of a mild bitter sharp
and then the sewallard crab we have some
examples of this in the back of the room
this is sort of a catch-all for hybrids
between the domesticated apple mouse
domestica and e-ensis which is the sort
of midwestern native species
and these are very similar to what i
described earlier of the the native
species they're sort of hard and green
and yellow very waxy and they're very
stringent very harsh but they're much
bigger
so they're big for a crab small for an
apple and so they've got sort of the
wild characteristics of the native
malice species but the size of the
domestica
and so these were historically found
throughout the midwest because apple's
very readily cross-hybridized among
species
and these were often used for top
working just because they were so cold
hardy they'd make a good tree and then
you grab something else on top later
and people also use them for preserves
crab apple wine for cider
and there were some other crab hybrids
that were mentioned the apples of new
york so matthews
we collected some fruit from this and
pressed juice of it and we tasted it
last year
and let me tell you it will strip the
enamel right off of your teeth it is
unbelievably tart i think it's the
highest acidity of anything we've
measured and the tannins
are probably among the highest we've
measured on anything as well um four to
four point four to five
um so you can see why people would use
it for cider it's definitely
a real tannin bomb as you might say
and then mercer this is kind of
interesting it's a triploid either
malice coronary or maybe malicious from
mercer county illinois and it's enormous
uh it's diameter is like 80 millimeters
tannins and acidity or nothing to sneeze
at either
so those are some other crab hybrids
that people use historically
and then this is one of my favorites
martha cram
um
so it's sort of a mild bitter sharp and
when it's ripe it's actually very nice
to snack on the tannins are sort of very
soft kind of velvety um it's really just
very tasty it's kind of again like big
for a crab apple small for an apple it's
like a nice little snack size
and it i've used it
in my own cider making it's really
lovely
and this was
discovered by peter gideon he was a
pomologist and uh horticulturist in
minnesota and he's probably most famous
for breeding the apple wealthy
um and so here's an engraving i believe
actually a photograph of martha crabb
from the apples of new york and clearly
it
merited mentioned by them
and you thought that it was an offspring
of malice piccata and i'd be interested
to see what the parentage of it is
so i'm going to come back to this idea
any apple used insider is a cider apple
well i think
we've cast that aside for at least for
this afternoon um but that is actually
sort of true for apple brandy any apple
used in brandy really is a brandy apple
um the character of an apple brandy
comes through from
barrel aging um it's so high proof
that's you know trying to detect this
particular note it's just
it's a fool's errand
um
and so that was sort of reflected in how
people made apple brandy so in new
jersey
if there was a really windy year and a
lot of
apples fell off of the tree
they'd say oh it's going to be a great
year for applejack because those apples
you know they're fall and they get
bruised they're not going to the fresh
market
um
and so
you know a windfall we think of as like
you know some money some unexpected good
fortune
um but it literally comes from
apples or other fruit that have been
knocked off the tree by the wind and
both of these can be true if you're an
applejack distiller
but so
as time went on and people were
moving away from cider as this sort of
really you know sort of the wine of
america into just sort of this
you know high-proof booze
people's attitude towards apples and to
growing apples specifically for cider
became much more sort of loose and
um
less i guess artisanal for lack of a
better word
um
and so you know the agricultural
improvement
movement uh was underway in the 19th
century people were
grafting over their orchards to eating
apples to export to england or to other
parts of the country
and so pc reynolds of rochester new york
in 1865 wrote there are about few old
orchards in the country that do not
contain some trees which are decidedly
unprofitable
some bare small sour natural fruit and
natural was a pejorative term
in those days only fit for cider or the
swine so that sort of really reflects
what people started thinking of
cider apples and cider as more generally
and
william allwood of virginia a professor
at virginia tech and
very important maher at the usda
said in the united states cider has been
in the past two generally regarded as a
product of very little importance from a
commercial standpoint and it has been
too often so made that most persons of
cultured taste have looked on it with
little approval when offered as a
beverage and so from being america's
most popular beverage now it's just sort
of this you know
throwaway agricultural byproduct um and
it would really come down in its
prestige and its esteem in america by
the by the early 1900s
and so you look at
census data there's a huge drop-off over
the decades in
the early 20th century in cider
production we don't know what happened
during national prohibition because it
was illegal to report
um but uh what we do know is that during
the second world war applejack actually
sort of regained popularity because
grain liquor um it was harder to make it
because all the grain was going to the
war effort
but if it was sort of this mass-produced
um you know industrial product it might
have sort of sowed the seeds of its own
demise by just being kind of badly made
um
and again you know the quality of apples
for brandy isn't really that important
so that it's not just the decline of
cider it's the decline of cider apples
as well going on
um so as i said um hard cider had sort
of become
from the sophisticated drink it became
sort of this backcountry thing that your
grandpa on the farm used to make
and then demographics really changed
america urbanized there was mass
immigration from countries that didn't
have a cider culture
the temperance movement and individual
states started passing prohibition and
anti-tavern laws
this all led to the decline of cider and
cider apples in america
and then um
you know what we think of as apple cider
is the sweet non-alcoholic stuff
pasteurization got better and so people
had ways to keep their cider from
going alcoholic and so gradually all
this conspired for basically the demise
of cider in america
so recently there's been quite a
renaissance of cider apples
there's been a cider revival of the last
decade or so
and there has been some continuity with
the historic tradition so the fine folks
at albemarle ciderworks for instance are
growing these historic varieties and
trying to do things in a historic style
but i did a survey of the north american
cider industry this year
and i spoke to a or heard from 198
commercial citeries in the us and canada
and what i found is that
first of all the vast majority of fruit
people are using is low tannin so
they're not they're using you know
leftover coal apples from processing or
from the fresh market they're not
growing these astringent cider apples
the way people did historically and then
even among people who are
growing these apples it's still a
minority of the apples they use for the
most part only about six percent of
people i spoke to said that it's the
majority of their fruit
and then when i asked people what
varieties they're growing
almost you know all the top dozen that
people mentioned they're all from
england or they're one or two from
france
um hughes virginia crab is the only
american one uh to actually make it into
the top dozen which i found i guess it's
not surprising but
hopefully that state of affairs will
change a little bit
and so in conclusion
i want to just point out for anyone who
didn't know already america has a rich
cider history of its own
and we've had many fine cider apples
arise here in our diverse climates
and um
there are actually some folks including
cider makers in the kyoglic area who
have been doing seedling uh
apple production in the sort of old
style cider way and i think that's a
very venerable american tradition
and um you know the the
industry today in the post-revival
period
it's very heavy it's very heavily
reliant on these european cultivars and
i love the european cultivars i did my
master's research on the european
cultivars they're wonderful they make
great cider
um i'm not a gatekeeper by any means but
this comes with horticultural challenges
and risks because these varieties came
about in a much milder climate with
different disease pressures
um and so you know
that's
that's something to keep in mind as we
um
as more people plant these varieties and
as the cider industry grows
um
and for the most part you know with a
couple of exceptions like hughes and
harrison and one or two others a lot of
these historical american cultivars have
sort of been
left out perhaps just because people
weren't aware of them or maybe
people weren't sure you know there
wasn't really much literature on them
that was successful
so you know
among other things i hope that the work
we've done in the peck lab highlights
the american as well as the european
cider apples and you know cider is a big
tent it's a new industry it hasn't
become ossified or calcified the way
other alcohol industries have yet
it's very dynamic and so hopefully it
can be a big enough tent to have room
for the american the european the
historical
and the modern
uh with that i'd like to acknowledge
the wonderful work of my lab mates
mike brown my co-worker who's been
putting up with me for the last five and
a half years in the peck lab nathan
wytena who began the field work in the
usda many years ago five years ago now
shantanu
ali britney
our fearless leader greg and our
wonderful summer interns who have helped
over the years
and i want to give a thank you to all
the promologists and historians who came
before me who
you know their writing and their work
really enabled me to do this research
with that
here are various uh sources that i've
referred to over the course of this talk
and i'll take any questions thank you
very much
i remember when i was a little kid we
grew up far far from wall and five
we used to go to the apple origins out
there
and they'd make the cider out of the
sweet
all the drops
and they looked horrible
but i remember the cider being delicious
so um
do you get delicious apples cider i mean
if you use the drugs
so
it will come back
yes so um
why are they so delicious well so
so the question was um
can you remember your name by the way
randy uh was asking um he grew up near
walden pond and he remembered drinking
sweet cider but it was made from the
apples that fell to the ground and can
you get good sight from them and the
answer is absolutely yes
drops are
typically when an apple is ripe it will
fall to the ground now for the fresh
market we do everything we can to
prevent that from happening because we
don't once it falls to the ground you
can't sell it in the fresh market but
the ripening process of apples typically
is they are ripest when they've fallen
and have been on the ground for a few
days
so
in the hard cider industry because it's
all fermented
there's less of a food
safety concern and so any um
pathogens uh are typically denatured in
the fermentation process and so there's
been a change in the um fda is the fda
or the usda fba
fda um guidance that they'll permit
um
they'll permit hard cider producers to
use ground harvested apples and in
england and france it's all ground
harvested so we're actually
like sort of neurotically safety
concerned as far as
cider in america goes so yeah ground
apples downside of having them drop on a
drop cloth
um the only downside is uh if you think
of it as a downside is that they get
kind of bruised but actually
um sort of bruising and it's sort of it
can improve the flavor of cider you get
sort of more caramelly kind of oxidized
tannins out of it um so it's it's all a
matter stylistically of what you prefer
one in the chat um
the need
um
you know every time people talk about
terroir my eyes glaze over because i
just my nose and my tongue can't really
detect subtleties that way but i think
they're
for the people who care about terroir i
think there is a need for studying it um
soil quality does affect the quality of
uh cider apples and apples more
generally not just minerality but sugar
content tanning content there's been a
bit of work on that from france so
definitely important yeah
i have a question about johnny appleseed
i don't know what you know about him but
apples are grafted so
was he like going around planting grassy
grafted apples from seed whiskey making
the grass himself
and what was his deal yeah so he was
planting seedling apples the question
was about johnny appleseed was he
planting by grafting or by seed so he
was planting by seeds and his object was
to have apples
apple trees i should say to lay claim to
land so if you had trees it didn't
matter what kind of trees there were as
long as you had the right number you had
a claim to a land parcel
and the other thing was um at this time
continental paper money it was really uh
subject to inflation it was practically
useless banks would just make up their
own money there would be like dollars
with owls on them it was crazy time in
america
totally unlike today right um
and so having a hard tradable good uh
was more useful and more economically
stable so people would actually have uh
johnny appleseed had contracts where
he'd say um you know in return for so
many apple trees in 10 years so and so
grants me this so he was using them not
just to leak claim but actually as a
hard tradable good basically currency
but he was growing see seedling trees
and he was leaving it to other people to
craft
a question is there any difference in
grafting for cider apples versus like a
fresh market
apple not at all nope they're all just
mutually compatible yep
uh have we gotten questions from geneva
by the way did i should i ask geneva
yeah that was that was that was the one
that came up about um
yeah
so so i don't know if you mentioned this
or not because i was so for all that was
a great talk thank you um
uh the difference between hard cider and
applejack
so applejack is uh distilled yeah
either cryo or in a heat still
david i was wondering if you could
explain a little bit more on the
cultural perception of how americans use
cider now because
myself and a lot of people who are
trying some of these ciders like the
ones brought today
are always anticipating at first at
least if you don't know ciders that will
kind of a sweeter drink and even
generically at the bars and things like
this ciders are pretty sweet when even
from the chemistry that you just shown
us there's astringency there's
bitterness there's sharpness so what
happened in america that made america's
current perception of cider to be this
really sweet drink and
how do you foresee that changing once uh
the tent gets larger as you said
um well history so the question was
about why do we think of cider so sweet
when historically it's not well first of
all
historic cider was often fairly sweet um
it you know would have some residual
sugar
the reason i think is one we lost
continuity with the historic tradition
two most of the apples we have have no
tannin you know maybe someone's got a
couple of crab apple trees as
pollenizers in their orchard uh and a
lot of cider this is sort of a dirty
secret that people don't want to admit a
lot of it's made with apple juice
concentrate from china or poland
and so
you know
and also frankly americans are still
addicted to sugar and sweetness
um
and you know i don't want to be
prescriptive in my tastes i just don't
like things that are particularly sweet
it's just me um and so i think we still
like
we wouldn't expect a pinot noir to be
sweet right we wouldn't expect
a chardonnay to be particularly sweet
and yet
for some reason just because
the market has been dominated by an
industrial product that's made with
juice concentrate
um
we've
gotten this perception that it's sweet
when it doesn't have to be
so so so i think that's changing right
because i i can't stand sweet cider and
i i didn't drink it for a long time
because and then my husband said no no
tried this dread as that
it was fantastic i mean it was really
good
and so you know all these sweet wines
you don't see them anymore so much so i
think i think i think you're in a great
position and this is gonna
continue to take off
i'm glad to hear that and i i should say
i mean there are plenty of very good
sweet ciders uh kiev or cedar cedra
boucher it's a very old tradition in
france and they starve the yeast so that
there's a lot of residual sugar um but
it's balanced by tannins so i think
people are more willing to
have uh to enjoy a sweet cider if
there's also some backbone to it if it's
not just tart and sweet um i was there
one more question in the back somewhere
yes is there a historical or current
tradition of using diseased apples to
make cider
diseased apples for cider
um
so when i when you look at um
like treatises and tracts on how to make
cider
so many of these
are usually men are writing and make
sure to only use the cleanest and you
know
least bruised and least diseased apples
those are the best for cider but if they
keep having to say it it implies to me
reading the gaps that a lot of people
are just taking the crappiest apples
from their orchard and making it into
cider so i think yes to answer your
question
uh so one quick question uh do the
european cult bars versus like the
american qualifiers that are around do
they have different means of mean degree
of polymerization so the degrees of the
did for their tenants so
like two to five or these are like five
to ten it's more of a chemistry based
question here yeah that is a great
question um i think there's there was a
little bit of metabolomic work done on
like 20 some cultivars from the usda
uh i i am not an hplc guy i would
imagine
i would imagine that there were plenty
of highly polymerized tenants and some
of the american cider apples just the
same as in europe
um and you know the the monomeric um
uh
uh i'm totally blanking on the name of
the monomeric phenolics but anyway
yeah yeah thank you thank you epic
against kerkins they're very bitter um
and the more polymerized the longer
chain you get the more astringent sort
of velvety chalky
um i don't think there's that much of a
difference in the european versus the
american i think it's more just tannin
or no tannin has been really the big
difference
yes
just wondering do you have any
information or studies from victoria
about the
[Music]
the effect of which stage sorry
ripening stage
as far as tannin goes
tannins are developed very early and so
there's not a strong correlation between
tan content and ripeness the big
difference is in acidity and sugar
content because starch has to be
hydrolyzed to sugar but i would say not
so much for 10. for aromatics i think
yes
any less
questions burning desires queries
random thoughts
yes
thomas jefferson so i want to defend
thomas jefferson defend thomas jefferson
wasn't that he was against the
constitution he wanted to include the
bill
including yes bill of rights
thank you
yes that's very important um
i nearly slandered and callum need
thomas jefferson so thank you for
defending him
uh
with that i think we're at time uh thank
you all you've been a lovely audience
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu